maz
what is the uh is there any off-limits
stories for comedians today
are there stuff that maybe you could
have touched 10 years ago
that you're better off just not touching
today listen man
it's an ever-evolving world i always say
that i think we need to grow as
individuals there's certain words that
were
said in the 50s that you can't say now
there's certain words that we're saying
in the 80s you can't say now
there's certain words that would say
five years ago you can't say now and i
think
on the one hand you know i have kids and
they sometimes
they show me and they
tell me and they lead and that makes me
believe in the future because i go wow
these kids are are progressive
and they see a world where all the
colors come together and it's not about
the color it's about it's about your
character either a good person or a bad
person right so
um i think that we need to grow i think
comedians though end of the day
we get to choose you live and die by the
laugh
so if you sit there and go i want to
tell this joke that's going to be
talking about something that let's say
is derogatory to women or is
misogynistic or
could be construed as racist or whatever
yeah you know if you're that passionate
about it
get on stage and try it and see what
happens because the audience will tell
you either they won't laugh
or they'll get up and walk out or
they'll laugh
you know there's some comedians who push
that envelope
and still come around with a punch line
that makes the audience
go oh my god i didn't see that coming um
and there's some a lot of comedians that
have been you know
canceled for things they said and the
unfortunate thing is nowadays on social
media too
you might just throw something out that
you think you know very
little about you might say oh whatever
uh gosh it's so dark today
uh blah blah blah and use some
terminology that might be construed as
racist but you weren't meaning it to be
that but then all of a sudden people are
coming at you and you're going oh no you
know
so that's also a different thing because
a lot of times people take things out of
context and and that's why i always tell
people i go if you're about to go i mean
unfortunately social media doesn't do
this but
i i would say it to the fans of that
person if you're going to
get upset at someone that you're a fan
of look at their
full history so if you know somebody
who's been let's say
an advocate for black lives matter and
has been
an activist and has been vocal
for uh racial equality and all that
stuff and then someone says oh they made
a racist tweet
then look at it and go oh was that an
intentional tweet was that a was that a
mistake
and and don't judge that person off that
one tweet look at their full
story but unfortunately social media
doesn't do that
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye